Merry Christmas!
90% of Americans in a November
Monmouth University poll say they plan
to celebrate Christmas, down slightly
from 96 percent who gave that response
in a similar Gallup poll a quarter
century ago. In a 2017 poll, the Pew
Research Center suggested that the
nature of Christmas may be changing,
driven in part by generational change. In
the poll, majorities of all age groups
felt that religious aspects of Christmas
were emphasized less than in the past,
but older people were bothered more by
this than younger ones. There is other
evidence of changing attitudes. 42% of
millennials,
compared to 58% of boomers, say
they plan to attend religious services
on Christmas Eve or Christmas day. 6
in 10 millennials, compared to 46
percent of boomers, say it doesn't matter
to them whether merchants say "Merry
Christmas" or "Happy Holidays".
Older people prefer "Merry Christmas".
Politics aside, more Americans find the
holiday season more enjoyable than
stressful compared to the rest of the
year, and around 8 in 10 planned to
gather with family and friends on Christmas.
Are you celebrating Christmas?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.